No es un secreto que Israel y los países
árabes nunca se han llevado precisamente
bien, de hecho, siempre se han llevado fatal:
3 guerras, decenas de conflictos diplomáticos,
acusaciones de todo tipo, vamos que el conflicto
árabe-israelí ha sido uno de los más calientes
de la segunda mitad del siglo XX.
Claro, cuando te llevas mal con tus vecinos
tienes un problema, pero si además estos
son los mayores productores de petróleo el
problema se multiplica, sobre todo si tenemos
en cuenta que Israel ha sido considerada siempre
como un erial energético: los intentos por
encontrar petróleo nunca tuvieron éxito.
Es verdad, que hasta 1979, Israel tenía un
buen aliado en la región ¿Sabéis cuál?
Creo que os va a sorprender: Irán.
Sí, así es, el Irán de los tiempos del
Sha de Persia era un estrecho aliado de Israel,
al fin y al cabo, se puede decir que eran
amigos con un enemigo común: los países
árabes.
La relación era tan estrecha que incluso
en 1978 Israel le ofreció ayuda al Sha de
Persia para construir centrales nucleares.
Pero todo cambio en 1979 con la revolución
de Jomeini, a partir de la cual Israel e Iran
pasaron de ser grandes amigos a grandes enemigos.
El caso es que Israel ha tenido siempre dos
grandes debilidades: una mala relación con
sus vecinos y tener problemas para garantizarse
el suministro de Petroleo, sobre todo ante
una situación de conflicto.
Así lo reconoció en 2004 el propio Ministerio
de Energía de Israel:
"la situación de Israel es complicada, no
tenemos relaciones diplomáticas con la mayoría
de los países de los cuales importamos petróleo”
Sin embargo, amigos, todo esto parece a punto
de cambiar.
EL REGALO DE DIOS
“El Regalo de Dios”, así es como Benjamín
Netanyahu, el Primer Ministro israelí, definió
los últimos descubrimientos que Israel ha
hecho en el Mar Mediterráneo, descubrimientos
que pueden cambiar para siempre la realidad
geoestratégica de toda esta conflictiva región
de Oriente Medio.
Pero, claro, puede que os estéis preguntando,
¿De qué descubrimientos estamos hablando?
Muy atentos a este mapa:
Cada pieza amarilla representa un yacimiento
de Gas Natural descubierto.
Y ojo porque no estamos hablando de yacimientos
precisamente pequeños.
El último en descubrirse, conocido como Leviathan,
es uno de los yacimientos más grandes descubiertos
en todo el mundo durante la última década.
Como hemos visto antes, Israel lleva desde
1952 haciendo todo lo posible por encontrar
petróleo o gas natural en su territorio para
lograr la independencia energética.
Pero hasta el año 2000 todos los intentos
fueron prácticamente en vano, apenas se encontraron
algunos micro-yacimientos de petróleo en
el desierto que no valían de mucho.
“Si hace diez o 15 años hubiera dicho que
Israel encontraría un depósito de energía
tan grande que le permitiría ser casi independiente
en materia energética, todos habrían pensado
que estaba loco.
Éramos el país de la leche y la miel; cuando
se trataba de petróleo, se lo dejábamos
a nuestros vecinos”.
Nati Birenboim, Tamuz Group.
Este primero fue pequeño, pero con él dio
comienzo la carrera, porque ya estaba claro:
debajo del mar, del fondo marino, había sorpresas.
Así que Noble Energy, continuó explorando
el fondo hasta que en 2009 hubo premio: descubrió
el yacimiento Tamar que este ya sí tenía
un tamaño respetable, de hecho, este yacimiento
le suministra hoy a Israel casi la mitad de
sus necesidades para producir electricidad.
Pero es que un año más tarde, a Israel,
literalmente, le tocó la lotería: en 2010,
tras gastarse 100 millones solo en la exploración,
Nobel Energy descubrió Leviathan, un yacimiento
gigantesco.
Para que os hagáis una idea se calcula que
este yacimiento es más grande que todas las
reservas de Gas Natural que a día de hoy
han sido descubiertas en países como Bolivia
o México.
Pero aquí no acaba la historia, porque casi
toda la zona está sin explorar.
De hecho, los estudios geológicos dicen que
ahí abajo a 5.000 metros de profundidad hay
muchísimo más gas natural y también….
Petróleo.
De hecho, el gobierno estima que el Mediterraneo
puede albergar en aguas israelíes una riqueza
descomunal de gas natural y petróleo.
De hecho, el gobierno estima que, en total,
los yacimientos podrían albergar más de
3billones de metros cúbicos de gas y 6.000
millones de barriles de petróleo.
Pero, vale, ¿qué son 3 billones de metros
cúbicos?
No es algo que fácilmente podamos visualizar,
¿verdad?
Pues para que os hagáis una idea si se confirman
las previsiones del gobierno, Israel, un país
pequeñito que apenas tiene unos 8 millones
de habitantes, podría entrar en el top 15
de países con más gas natural y en el top
20 de países con más petróleo.
Y claro, no todo es para ellos, las exportaciones
ya están comenzando.
Precisamente a finales de 2016 las empresas
propietarias han llegado a un acuerdo con
el gobierno de Jordania para convertirse en
su mayor suministrador durante los próximos
15 años.
El contrato supera los 10.000 millones de
dólares.
Y, ojo, entre el 50 y el 60% de todo este
importe irá directamente a las arcas del
gobierno israelí.
Así, es, amigos de VisualPolitik, el gobierno
de Israel va a ingresar decenas de miles de
millones en las próximas décadas, y si se
confirman sus estimaciones podríamos estar
hablando de cientos de miles de millones.
Y aun, hay más.
Porque en Israel continental petróleo convencional
parece que no hay, pero podría haber ingentes
cantidades de petróleo de esquisto, el que
se extrae a través del fracking.
De hecho, los primeros yacimientos ya se han
encontrado.
Es decir, no es ya que Israel vaya a conseguir
la independencia energética, algo que parece
claro, sino que además podría llegar a convertirse
en toda una potencia energética.
Ahora ya sabéis porque Netanyahu considera
estos descubrimientos como un regalo de Dios.
Hace años, la exprimer ministro, Golda Meir
hizo famoso este chiste:
“Déjenme decirles algo que nosotros los
israelíes tenemos contra Moisés.
¡Nos llevó 40 años a través del desierto
para traernos al único lugar de Medio Oriente
que no tiene petróleo!”
Pues parece que las tornas están cambiando.
Si a todo ello le sumamos que Israel es el
país más innovador del mundo, puede que
en los próximos años llegue a convertirse
también en uno de los más ricos.
Por cierto, ¿sabéis quiénes fueron los
primeros en interesarse por estos yacimientos?
Los rusos.
Hace unos años Gazprom quiso comprarlos,
al fin y al cabo, todo apunta a que en pocos
años Israel podría arrebatarle al gas ruso
una parte de su cuota de mercado en Europa.
Y es que ya lo sabéis, nos lo contó Fonseca,
con el vídeo sobre Arabia Saudita y Trump:
la energía supone dinero… y también
influencia.
NUEVOS ALIADOS
La situación internacional de Israel ha sido
siempre cuando menos controvertida: Guerras,
conflictos políticos, denuncias internacionales,
resoluciones de Naciones Unidas, vamos que
el Ministerio de Asuntos Exteriores de este
país tiene más trabajo que Papa Noel en
plenas Navidades.
El caso es que, aunque pueda resultar chocante
si tenemos en cuenta los últimos acontecimientos
en Naciones Unidas:
El Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU aprueba
resolución que condena los asentamientos
israelíes
Y por supuesto los descubrimientos energéticos
han ayudado un montón.
Por ejemplo, las relaciones con sus vecinos
están mejorando a pasos agigantados:
Con Turquía las relaciones, que se rompieron
casi por completo en 2010 cuando Israel abordó
la Flotilla de la Libertad, se están recomponiendo.
Seguramente tiene mucho que ver el hecho de
que el país de Erdogan es un enorme consumidor
de Gas Natural y que sus acuerdos de importación
con Rusia vencen en apenas 5 años, y ya sabemos
cómo andan las relaciones entre ambos países.
Turquía derriba un caza ruso en la frontera
con Siria
Con sus otros vecinos árabes, Egipto y Jordania,
la cosa también va viento en popa.
No solo es que Israel se haya convertido en
el mayor proveedor de Gas de Jordania sino
que las relaciones con Egipto están tan bien,
que su ministro de exteriores, Sameh Shoukry
estuvo viendo la final de la última Eurocopa
en la residencia del Primer Ministro de Israel,
valga como prueba.
Incluso lo impensable…
Arabia Saudí e Israel fortalecen lazos tras
la máscara de una ruptura diplomática
Otro país con el que también ha estrechado
mucho las relaciones es con la Grecia de Tsipras
que, sorprendentemente, se ha convertido en
un aliado muy cercano.
De hecho, hoy la fuerza aérea israelí se
entrena en el país heleno.
Pero, sobre todo, el cambio más importante,
es en el acercamiento a Oriente.
En vídeos anteriores os contamos como Obama
apostó por el Pacífico, pues podemos decir
que Israel ha hecho lo mismo.
Y en este proceso la India se ha jugado un
papel clave.
Este país ha convertido a Israel en su segundo
mayor proveedor de armas después de Rusia
y en la última década, la India le ha comprado
a Israel más de 10.000 millones de dólares
en equipamiento militar.
Las relaciones son tan buenas que, en 2015,
por primera vez en la historia, el Presidente
de la India hizo una visita oficial a Israel
y desde entonces los encuentros se han repetido
con mucha frecuencia.
Por cierto, un apunte, hasta ahora Grecia
y la India habían sido países muy críticos
con Israel como consecuencia de la situación
de Palestina, así que ya podéis imaginaros
que en el Ministerio de Asuntos Exteriores
israelí esto se ve como todo un logro.
Y sí, también, con China Israel está cuajando
una relación bastante estrecha y de hecho
están negociando un acuerdo de libre comercio.
Además, empresarios chinos están realizando
fuertes inversiones en el país e incluso
están construyendo un puerto en la ciudad
de Ashdod dentro de su plan de la ruta de
la seda.
Y también Vietnam, Corea del Sur…
en fin la apuesta de Israel por Asia está
siendo todo un éxito.
Y sí, también está Donald Trump que de
momento se ha comprometido a:
En fin, amigos, aún queda mucho camino por
recorrer hasta que Israel pueda convertirse
en una potencia energética, pero de lograrlo
puede tener un efecto muy positivo para la
estabilidad de la zona, lo que sin duda sería
una muy buena noticia.
Israel se está convirtiendo en un gran país,
pero aún quedan oscuros, desde luego todos
lo conocemos, el conflicto con Palestina que
ha de solucionarse.
La fortuna es que unas mejores relaciones
con sus vecinos árabes podrían ayudar mucho
a este objetivo.
Bueno, tú que piensas ¿Contribuirá toda
esta riqueza energética a la resolución
del conflicto?
¿Logrará Israel aprovechar esta oportunidad
para convertirse en uno de los países más
ricos del mundo?
Como siempre, esperamos vuestros comentarios
y si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no dudéis en darle a like y suscribiros al
canal si aún no lo has hecho.
Y por supuesto no dejes de visitar nuestro
canal en inglés.
Por cierto, si queréis saber cómo logró
Israel el milagro de convertirse en la Tierra
de la innovación y las Start-ups no te pierdas
este vídeo.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.